foreign
student who got signed as a Gatorade
ambassador
because of his awesome name what is that
Gatorade Ambassador was it like power
what do you think it is the power glitch
power quench what's his last name
hydration
huh
sport yeah that's a pretty good guess
it's not sport what's his name
you show me tell you his name's drink
water shut up dude I swear to God what's
his name and the Gatorade is like we're
a sponsor him but then it's not it's not
water yeah Nestle doesn't it promote
Kirkland's Gatorade down yeah
is it is that his last name or his full
name his name is drinkwater Rivera
drinkwater yeah that's his name that's
his name why did they choose that name
because when his mom was pregnant uh she
I think she would just drink a lot of
water to in order to feel better like
she couldn't get through the uh
pregnancy unless she drank water is that
that was like her story
his name's drink water that's it so she
goes huh honey you make me drink water
so much your name's gonna be drink water
so in the commercial that they have them
signed to uh he goes the slogan that he
says
he goes I may be drink water but when
it's time to exercise I drink Gatorade
no sugar
wow dude yeah his his name is a phrase
dude the marketing team's like right
dude how much to get Bernie in a
commercial to be like I love capitalism
let's go forward buy a Ford car
and I love capitalism is it isn't it
Bernie kind of like a Real Estate Mogul
anyway yeah you've got like three houses
but dude I remember you know who uh
who's that cat he's like kind of like
part of the grunge Rock movement
[__] Kurt Cobain no no no no no Dave
Grohl no no no older than that
I watched him and do a Ford commercial
for the Super Bowl and I was like Oh
Henry Rollins no it was that'd be
[__] interesting
someone nuts someone like Jack Kerouac
doing like Captain Ozzy Osbourne it was
like that GiGi Allen nah well I mean
when dudes get older they got
responsibilities so they can't be so
punk rock anymore you know I mean this
this kid is definitely like in a good
position to accept a Gatorade signing
he's like he's like sure he's a
Philippines kid what's his uh sport what
sport does he do
um none hang on please oh wait sorry oh
[__] so he just he just I'm sorry bro I
think he think that I was gonna stump
him I don't think it's a signup I
thought that was a layup he does
I think he's just exercises so just he's
a fitness dude I guess I don't know if
he's in anything dude he's just a kid
then that's his name wow Dylan
Bob Dylan Bob Dylan did a [__] like
grunge I was thinking 90s growing no it
was like there's like crunch
that is weird so like
yeah he's like anti-established exactly
but then he's like he's like yeah Toyota
like it's [__] you got to get one
they're pretty sick four-wheel drive
leather seats
what do you think his siblings names are
I don't know dude
okay well wait pickles yeah pickles
pickles eat pickles drink water eat
pickles he has two siblings
air conditioning and then something
completely normal that's Filipino Eric
damn you damn you maybe that's what
she's saying to her husband when she's
giving birth so then she named him damn
you breathe there drink water
and eat pickles eat pickles all right
pickle sandwiches with the pregnant lady
pickle thing because you two got an
answer who doesn't like pickles his uh
his siblings names are winner and rice
why don't they have Filipino names do
they do English names out there a lot
yeah oh my mom said that when she was
pregnant she just wanted to drink
Hennessy that's what he looks like if
you want to see him [__] get rid of
you yeah she just had like a craving for
Hennessy I think you're kind of fine
dude it's like a little boy
yeah but I think it's funny that so in
the commercial they made it it's like
literally just about his name the whole
thing
are they running out of athletes to
sponsor that's cool that they're hooking
them up though they better hook them up
they better not be using them yeah they
better be [__] getting them because
again it's it's like Gatorade exists in
the Philippines so they have their own
Philippines oh branch Philippine
marketing yeah it's not like yeah yeah
every you know every brand like Pepsi or
whatever they're doing their own
commercial that we don't always see
so you think that because this guy is
now prominent because of this he will
name his kid drinkwater junior or
something like that like you know what I
mean kind of keep that juice going a
little bit that's probably these kids
eat chicken do you think you can score a
Jolly B one I wonder if he like has a
feeling about his name or his whole
family does you know some kids they just
don't like their name or like why'd you
name it naked passionate threshold of
being made fun of like you could
surprise school yeah when she had made
fun of what do you think thank you I
believe that no one thank you no one at
all
[Laughter]
do you think there's places that still
preserve that bullying and they're just
like we're traditionalists I think okay
I like Malta I like that so widespread
piracy
I heard Somali is pretty good for
bullying too yeah
I think we have a couple people in Malta
that watch JK too I've seen that before
shout out to them I've seen I've seen a
comment nice people the bullies someone
here once said mentioned Malta in like
an article and then there was a guy in
the comments like [__] yes
shout outs to Malta I was like that's so
cool
when I hear these obscure countries I
forget that people speak English outside
of America yeah and I'm like wow or you
forget how much other countries just
know lots of languages and we're just
idiots yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
there's a whole last Czech community
that watches our [__] oh really yeah
Czech Republic
Czech Republic yeah around the globe or
else
they're hot very nice Czech women are I
wasn't very nice yeah and then there's
like hella Vietnamese people there too
they're like Vietnamese Community like a
nice huge one like thousands of them but
yeah and [__] Czech look but they're
you know how like Slovakia there's a
different country I almost said
Czechoslovakia it's a Czech Republic you
know how out here we got the Vietnamese
refugees that are like South Vietnamese
those are the commies because you know
the Czech Republic used to be Soviet
Union it used to be Communists right
yeah so then um the North Vietnamese
they used to have a work program so they
went out there and then when they became
a part of like the the other countries
that are not Communists when Soviet
unions fell they're just like we're
gonna stay okay and then the Vietnamese
folks just stayed rad yeah they're like
we're gonna open up fall restaurants
and then so all those kids they they
learn English at school and [__] right
and then they would watch JK well oh
very cool shaping Generations right they
thought you would get two for a long
time huh I don't know but they watched
JK though and I was like damn that's
crazy man dude when I was in seventh
grade there was a chick from the Czech
Republic and she was like the hottest
chick I ever saw in my life they're
really hot so because of that I think
the Czech women are all hot don't you
love that don't you love that it's
basically just one bias yeah like the
sample size of that is it could not be
smaller yeah I don't know we're not
English girls when I was there I saw all
these hot grandmas working at the
Christmas Market and I was like check
women baby
I love how quickly like that's your
world like you just meet like I had one
polish one beautiful girl that's all you
need I can't they all be like polish
girls
and you go to Poland I know yeah like I
know now
normal human beings and in seventh grade
you're like where's all the hot ones we
romanticize everything so I was like I'm
gonna marry a [__]
gym of all things a California Girl
yeah
definitely that's the funniest [__] what
do you think about naming your kid
something that could specifically help
their career
apprehensions about that I'll say this I
never ever would have thought naming a
kid drink water would get them a gay
race Monster Ship so already I'm already
at a disadvantage so I'm already like
I'm not thinking big enough dude tubers
I can't believe nobody's name because
subscribe click the Bell oh I honestly
because I just looked down on on us so
much yeah because we've really gotten in
the mud
like everyone gets their hands so
[__] very dirty you know what's gonna
happen they should have they should name
a like and like for the algorithm
like and like for the algorithm the
moment a tuber uh names their kids
subscribe and like they're gonna change
the algorithm the whole model and it's
not going to be anything with
subscriptions or liking it's going to be
a whole different thing would you name
your kid hit the like button
would you name your kid like undefeated
or something no dude that's setting up
oh my God bro imagine as soon as he gets
defeated kids like every the first fight
he's like oh like no you should have
three games my kid is not gonna be a
[__] this is what you do you have
three kids name the first one could be
undefeated lawyer
so you have three kids right name the
first one B second one b and then J BJJ
[Laughter]
anything fight related bro that's crazy
dude name your kid [__]
and they will be the toughest
[__] that ever lived oh you're
talking my language yeah hacks man these
are hacks yeah well because you know
that song like by Johnny Cash like he's
like my name is Sue and all this [__]
he's like my dad name is Sue because I
wanted him to not be a [__] or whatever
and it's like dude if you you can't my
kids soon name your kid Sue now and
everyone's gonna give him a standing oh
yeah yeah you got to go harder than that
you wouldn't want to name your kid
something that could pun very well with
your last name
like what well
like done done well done well done what
else
done
anything with that [__] 10 minutes of
this
[Music]